I have a game to show you and then we'll
do some more studies okay this game I'm
playing with the white pieces and my
opponent is about twenty three fifty
ready player and it's a very good
positional game where you see the
control of the center and space is very
very important in chess so d4 Knight f's
d4 d69 f3 Knight f6 c4g 693 Bishop g7 d4
and now what is the name of this opening
this is one of the most popular openings
against the force Kings Indian defense
and I decided to play the classical
setup so I got my Center pawn so I got
my Knights out so got a control castles
Bishop e2
each five
96 before and this is the called the
bionet attack so black will try to
attack usually what black tries to
attack on a king side and white is a
positional advantage on the Queen side
so it's sort of a race and there are
some really great games played in this
opening you know some very nice wins for
black some good wins for white as well
it's very sharp because you're being
under attack so you have to watch out
and to make precise moves here with
white also so 9 h5 now a my opponent put
the night there and he is threatening
let's first think about it and try to
see what is the threat here what is he
trying to do with Knight h5 yes he wants
to play a 5 that's one thing but if
let's say you can make a move again here
force what would you do here what's the
purpose of the night on h5 he can go
Knight f4 he wants to go Knight
therefore and win the bishop if he can
win one of the bishops here it will be
great to be light square or dr. bishop
you'll have a great position
okay so Knight h5 he's trying to go
Knight therefore so I need to do
something against that and the best
thing to do it is g3 restricting it when
opponent is trying to come in into your
territory most of the time you should
just make a pawn move to stop the piece
from coming in if that particular square
has a pawn that is controlling because
if you don't do that then he's gonna
come in and then you have a hard time
actually pushing this piece away okay so
that's why you play g3 to control
f-five he is attacking he wants to play
a four and wants to pressure only for
what is the best move here wide to play
try to find the best move excellent idea
excellent idea Knight g5 activating
knowing your knight attacking his knight
on d5 h5 and have the potential to go
tonight only six okay Knight g5 and
putting pressure Knight f6 and now he is
threatening to play h6 attack my knight
and if the knight moves he is gonna win
my pawn so there is there is a danger
here of losing the pawn here what should
I do here because I don't want to lose
the pound
you could but then when we sort of give
up the century now then he takes back
and he has a good Center see he's got
this it's got this it's got this he's
got it's got a lot of control in the
center
could go bish birthday that's a
possibility not bad also not bad
those suppose are playable but what is
the best what is the best way to protect
afore to make sure you're guarding that
permanently of course see protected
permanently if you protect with a piece
then that piece can be moved and then we
still have to worry about it so we want
to protect it permanently like this King
h8 now I had few options the move in the
game was fine very interesting move but
there was also another alternative here
so you have two good moves here moving
the game or the alternative can you find
those two clever moves here where are
those two playable moves here
but why why go away there is some
potential danger here right
on the king so don't want to go away
because then you could in there could be
some potential attack oftentimes your
knight goes here in these positions when
it gets kicked with h6 often times you
have to go here okay this is the idea
it was a pot fine move we could that I
played b5 in the game because I wanted
to have more control of the c6 square so
when I go 96 he takes I can just plant
my knight on d5 without the problem of
c6 but there was another alternative
here
I played b5 but I could have also played
the move Bishop e3 because I'm not quite
I'm not sure this does anything because
I just go back we should have 2 then I
have a bishop on a good diagonal will
attack and also will protect my king if
there are some potential attacking ideas
coming from black ok I probably would
have preferred to play Bishop b3 if I
had the opportunity to play this
position again but if again moving the
game is fine too p5 controlling c6
making it more difficult for him to
challenge now he goes here very
interesting move now black ghost Knight
to g8 the idea is to go Queen e7 and
then play h6 and if I go 96 take twice
an hour down upon
possible but how's that helping us if he
goes Queenie seven and then start trying
to play h6
excellent 96 he wants to go Queen d7 and
then play its XO I realized that that's
why I go in first because now if he
takes and goes here what is the strong
move here immediately takes 97 fork
winning exchange and if captured I will
gladly take back with a pawn and now I
have my pawn protected only six years
okay perfect
so he takes he takes only for Fe I take
back look eight block is simply trying
to win my pawn and then say okay where
is the compensation for the sacrifice
pawn so I don't like to lose I want to
point out very important moment here if
black was here first
it looks like my pawn is gone here
actually I have a good idea here what
would be the best way to play here for
white if you place the move rook e8 here
what would be the best way to play it
very close very close very close
Larry better improve that the first one
was great but second one not so good
because I have a four absolutely Quincy
Joe and now simply attacking the pawn so
I go Queen c2 and f5 is under attack he
cannot do anything got it perfect
so it took two rookie eight
now pawn is under attack and if I lose
the pawn then I will still have some
compensation or question about it but
not as much as I like absolutely why
lose it right why lose the pawn if we
can protect it protect it Bishop g4 if
he if captured then I want to capture
back with the Queen again this 95 is
causing problems because very strong
take take take and here attack attack
okay
so that's why my opponent played the c6
which is a good move because protecting
the d5 square so now no ideas like 95 I
can't jump in on d5 with the night what
should I do now
a3 bishop a
we should've ever couldn't be six check
problem how about we keep our lights go
Bishop what do you think of that idea he
had a chance he had an opportunity to
take it but he didn't so maybe it makes
sense now to try to protect this bishop
so we have the advantage of pair of the
bishops absolutely and now the question
is what is this Knight doing here see
the idea was to take and jump in back
with other night but now black cannot do
that anymore
and if I had one more move just one more
move to put my bishop here this would be
in strategically winning already for me
strategically because I would stop the
screen b6 attack but my opponent
opponent was counting on it
so Queen b6 check plate may now we've
got some options here we have two
retreats with the King we can block it
with the rock
now easy idea here let's see when you
have a choice it's easy to go wrong when
you have a choice
yes it's possible
I don't think moving the king is bad but
I had another idea in mind you could
move which square you prefer to move G 2
or H 1 Bishop yeah
see this is the that's why I'm showing
you this game for a decisions like this
because real-life game
decision needed it seems so simple but
still it's just king aatrox would some
King Jay King g2 is fine but what else
what else can you do here that's what I
played because I anticipate in some
point I would need to double up the
rocks and I don't see immediately what
he can do to take advantage of the pin
it's it's unusual move but it's a very
concrete move based on a concrete
calculation I'm not making this small
because it just looks good it's concrete
calculation because I knew my opponent
will play Queen d4 and looks looks like
some trouble here my pants are hanging
my knight is loose I cannot exchange
Queens because my pants will fall what
to do
looks like maybe I did something wrong
here bishop
excellent excellent job they should be
to developing a peace always remember if
it gets complicated development comes
first
developing peace strengthening
everything but the c4 pawn is hanging
see that's the thing my opponent didn't
take the pawn on c4 in the fear of
losing the pawn on d6 okay this was the
problem my opponent was fearing to lose
the pawn on d6 so I decided to play the
move rook a d1 but now I am no longer
planning to give my c4 pawn so he if
capture once before I had Queen d6 white
is better but now what do you know how
to consolidate a position and push the
enemy piece back because the Queen is
very active on d4 so now consolidation
needed excellent Bishop h6 what is the
threat Bishop e3 trying to come in and
take advantage of that pin what do you
do
of course rook the one rookie sitting
here on the side of the board actually
no maybe not oh I just remember sorry if
you play rugby 1 you are allowing Queen
III idea and black is remaining somewhat
still active okay so that's why I didn't
want to allow him to come in here I
played the move rook e1 and now I am
threatening some discovery attacks on
the Queen so the Queen is not very
comfortable anymore on d4 somehow came
in but now time to go back because
otherwise discovery attacks will be very
very strong so my opponent went back
now
what to do here
absolutely kingi to prophylactic move
you go away from the pin and now you
protect many things and you can also
double up your looks later Bishop g7
now what do we do next
d1 the target is this six
let's put pressure on the target okay
let's put pressure on the target
I completely okay fun also but I can't
do anything anyway this night on g8 is
protecting it so I thought maybe I
should just try to put pressure on that
bomb h5 now plate now the next idea is
very interesting you're gonna like the
final position of this game with my
opponent resigned and you will be like
really Bishop 83
how about c1 look at that excellent
square that is Bishop going to
permanently it will be very strong there
cannot be removed and I can also do some
Bishop III moles if I want which p3 was
okay but he would just go Queen c7 this
should be better on g5 king h7 my
opponent is trying to play Bishop h6 in
some point to exchange and then take
back with the king now what do you do
g5 pin it
continue keep going now rook d3 idea
behind this move is I would like to
bring when I look here and have the
opportunity to go triple up you see it a
lot of players I think would play this
move and then suddenly there is no way
to put more pressure because you got a
maximum here two rooks and a bishop so
you have to try to look for some
different ideas sometimes so the move
rudy 3 is very strong because I would
like to put a rock on f3 2 rooks on that
file and Queen goes back on f1 that's
triple up opponent cannot do anything
now so a6 was played trying to create
some destructions what do we do
continue with a plan when you choose a
plan you stick with it you don't need to
get destructed you go there now you
ready to take one f6 and expose the
position and rook will enter to the
seventh rank he needs to protect he
needs to react somehow now one more
strong move needed almost I did
something else just to make sure I shut
down all the counter play I want to shut
down all the country play here make sure
he's not going anywhere there on that
Queen side a four that's a possibility
now I really want to play Queen a farmer
I just didn't want to calculate this
captures here excellent
that's the move he can't take because
now you have another pawn push letter
fork and drops the knight and the game
see two deflections one the Queen one
the night and they pick up the loose PC
one f6 so it was Queen e7 and now big
trouble it's sook the bank black is like
in in Zuke's a bank cannot do anything
cannot move anything now what's the next
move to put him into that structure Bank
because black wants to escape now if
you're not paying attention you know you
do that Queen f1 know what can my
opponent do here cannot move the Queen
Bishop Knight rook on f8 I think you is
this so let's try play here
I really enjoyed this game because
that's what I'm showing you because
complete domination here where you see
the one white pieces are dominating
completely dominating the black game
ended very quickly here my opponent just
resigned I think maybe next move is I
okay I can I can do some a4 but then he
plays a 5 I can just do back and four
but ok I need a plan here and I need you
to spend some time here and find that
plant find the winning plan here
what is the winning planet takes
politics
it's a hard move next one hard mortified
you can do it
hmm it depends the way you look at it
then huh
okay you haven't really boxed in here
you cannot get more boxed in than this
it's hard to imagine you get a position
where black has all the pieces on the
board but cannot move anything
this is scat doesn't get more sucks of
anger than this king each one but okay
what's the plan huh a King h8 he goes
Mali 91-93 it's an idea yeah but then
you gotta watch out for some d5 at some
point there you know because you lose
the control I like to still keep the
control you can see he can maybe just
break through you know unleash a
breakthrough you know
huh
excellent all you need to do here is
expose the position of opponents King
here and g4 will do the task because
Queen Knight cannot take because of the
pin and if pawn takes that was the last
move of this game actually believe it or
not it came a little surprise to me too
when my opponent stopped the clock and
resigned but we will see now why because
there's absolutely no chance here no
contra play if you take Y just takes and
you make just a move and what is the
winning idea
don't rush check
check game off
we deflect the defender so that's one
way to win if it takes so cannot take
back with the night and also allowing me
to take would be bad because then my
bishop comes in check there should be
six inch very bad H what is the only
idea to at least keep it closed but now
I win also how we should take spawn
absolutely
okay here's to take this pawn here
because what else to do so takes the
pawn g5 but here you don't want to rush
you could play g5 right away also
but I think there is something a little
better because then a my bishop is sort
of trapped on h4 I don't think my bishop
will be too useful when I play g5
fishkrap six first bravo takes now g5 if
the Queen moves we just take the knight
so has to go tonight g4 what do you do
take what the rook not the nine Queens
you forecheck
if he takes you just go Queen to f8 and
winning material if it goes check
what do you do now do you three III
check anyway but not g3 Kim Jiwon takes
up a whole piece okay even in winning
positions you cannot relax as soon as
you relax then you will miss something
okay so that was my idea to take on a
children now I take on f6 and get this
with g5 same thing will happen if
opponent takes with the rook I can take
now it goes on g4 and what is the need
move here to win that piece maybe a few
ways to do it but
yeah absolutely you go Queenie - and
after you go Queenie - you putting
pressure on g4 and black is losing the
piece okay yeah it's it's a bit strange
that my opponent resigned after g4 but
as you can see here it's a complete
sucks along here none of the pieces
cannot move g4 was that that final touch
ish that when you have a position like
this where you have complete control
that opponent just just going back and
forth like here just going back and
forth here you just need to find the
last idea to break through and that idea
was g4 and black resigned here okay
okay excellent now at the end we will be
doing a study a difficult study white to
play and win if you want you can write
down this position it's a very unique
position there are only few pieces on
the board and you can save this white to
play and win let me just show you the
problem here because you may think wait
a minute why is this a problem but
problem is we have all these extra
pieces but he has got two threats
promote and take and if we somehow can
win this pawn or you know sacrifice any
piece for it we'll win but we can't
that's why now we have to bring
extraordinary measures here to win
that's the only way to win it well let's
try to find the idea not just move by
move check he goes away
because if you move the 90 Quinn's yeah
if you move the bishop he win Quinn's so
you have no choice so as the first move
was already suggested is roopd a check
here he has to go here because if he
goes to see one you just easily win
after Bishop e2 okay don't take with a
bishop okay don't take with a bishop
bloom they still made take back with the
rock okay so I just go check and you
just went okay sorry goes here now what
to do
pawn takes Knight Queen yeah but you
lose your knight to see you lose your
night to on the way and you only have
that way the bishop sir I know but
unfortunately that would that won't
change the result of the game because
there's it's impossible to mate with a
bishop you did get rid of the pawn but
unfortunately the price you paid you
know just was too much you lost your
knight see we gave up five and eight
eight four just to get that pawn off c1
queen check wait what is your move
when you don't know what to do what do
you do just check it okay now if he
takes he loses you go check he steps
away you pick it up the problem is if it
takes your night he actually helps you
because it's only one thread now left
and if you go see it you can just go
Bishop here and sacrifice so he goes
here
well if you keep checking then we're
gonna be signing the score sheets green
to draw King takes d1 now I take it
because you no longer have a check from
D file very tricky bravo Bravo
93 don't immediately think oh he
promotes into a queen e we lose keep
going keep going a little deeper but
you're not done yet
check I can't go here because you have
Roxy a check but I still have this no
task is not accomplished yet what we are
going to do to do that two moves two
moves away from victory
they should check he goes to u1 he
escapes actually he won f2 and then he
runs with what again don't know what to
do check he you know he can't go here
because he have this check right so he
has to go here now you're pinned the
knight cannot move over
unfortunately because it spent
absolutely paint
who is the thread well yeah when you
need to create immediate threats because
my Queen starts checking your King has
no coverage look HEA there is not a go
Queen c6 and stop the screen h1 your
threat
better
from graph a yes so I heard something
awestruck afraid now threatening to come
here check and mate and he cannot go
anywhere with the King because all the
squares are taken so now it's mating net
here you go here and if he goes here
what do you do no let's give a check
let's win the Queen and still have the
rock they'll be easier to checkmate
excellent job very tough study thank you
very much for coming and we will see you
next time okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]